das gericht ging dass der check gibt
russischen druck manager einmarschieren
waren wir gar nicht überrascht denn wir
hatten wir haben and goals das ist im
seewinkel eine außenstelle die funk
außenstelle war für das österreichische
bundesheer und da konnte man sämtliche
bewegungen und auch geräusche
feststellen erwarten werden tag vorher
schon informiert und hat druck aber
nichts gesagt und damit sie gut schaffen
können dann aber dann ist am 5 früh am
nächsten tag am 21
er ging an befehlen uns nach diesem
lampe fädeln war meine kompanie um 8 uhr
voll marschweg bereit und wir hätten
abrufen können nun verzögerte sich
dieser zustand um acht stunden
die truppe wusste zwar nicht was da los
war
wir haben überhaupt über über
funktelefon mich erkundigt beim
militärkommando schock da gibt es in
welchen schwierigkeiten eben zwischen
innenministerium und landes wird das
mysterium wer den befehl zum abrücken
der truppe in dieser 1 hat zwei mit gibt
alle an der linie westerbach horn
dollars ein zweiter bis freistaat stadt
zu nimmt also verlegte truppen durften
diese linie nicht überschreiten
wir wussten dass vor uns als er nach
osten und nach norden der schotter marie
schon mit 960 mann dessen sicherungs
test übernommen hatte
im einvernehmen mit der zollwache ich
möchte sagen dass die truppe diesen
dieses diese verlegung gut verkraftet
hat es hat keine disponieren
verfehlungen gegeben
es wurde auch freizeit gestaltend
gearbeitet sie durften ins kino gehen
geschlossen und verschiedene andere
programme besuchen und es lief alles
bestens ab eines möchte ich vielleicht
abschließend noch sagen dass es sowohl
die schlägertruppe die verlegten jäger
truppenteile als auch die panzer
kanadier truppen entlang dieser linie
die ich vorher geschildert habe bedauert
haben nicht mit ihrer truppe direkt dann
an der grenze sicherungseinsatz
betreiben zu dürfen